foreign
episode of the careful boys today we
have with us a special guest Mr
Christian Pierce
thank you for being here man happy to be
here it's really cool to have you man
I've seen a lot of yourself back in the
day and it's it's cool to meet you face
to face you're as cut and cool yeah as I
always imagine you know if I'm cool yet
you're pretty free you look pretty cool
dude where do you know him from
they're from online just like you're
Jimmy's writing partner right yeah yeah
yeah Jimmy Tatro yeah I don't know I
used to watch like my my first video
that I watched of you guys was the beat
drop one and the living room nice yeah I
really like that one and I was following
you guys the whole time and then I
remember fast forward to maybe like
maybe like four or five years ago
um like Nadine would always come a
barber with just random people and then
I saw you I was like
and nice
it's like yeah yeah yeah all right that
was kind of Jack dude what the [__]
it's always people always get surprised
like I work out and [__] because I feel
like in comedy like there's not a lot of
room for that it hasn't been
traditionally like you can't be like in
shape and funny Kevin Hart was a first
yeah probably and he also made Fitness
funny I'm trying to get my workout in
whatever right yeah yeah yeah yeah
people aren't surprised I still always
wear like biggest t-shirts I used to
wear a bunch of big shirts hoodies and
stuff like that because I also thought I
was like it's not funny to be cut like
yeah yeah regular yeah yeah it can't be
funny and be all but Bobby Lee was like
the hell is wrong with you you're not
gonna be funny anymore yeah and he was
really mad at me damn did you feel like
some of that was true did you feel like
you lost some of your funniness when you
got leaner no I just thought he was
jealous yeah I think he was trying to
make himself feel good yeah yeah he's
like you need to be you need to be fat
like me yeah that's what I do alcoholic
you were away from here yeah let's drink
together
mad at David for losing weight huh yeah
wait who lost weight David so
when he was fatter I think so because
his roles were all funny now he's trying
to do some serious [__] he's taking the
Jim Carrey route I think he has good
serious roles too though huh I think
he's a good actor yeah he's a good actor
is it what kind of is he doing funny
shows and movies though because all of
his stuff I've seen lately have been
drama yeah he just did a movie called
you people that was like it's a comedy
but he definitely and he was funny but
he definitely played like a cooler less
comedic character he was a cool guy yeah
do you like want him to be funny when
you watch him too because I feel like I
do I'm like waiting for him yeah I think
he's like grandfather funny to me like
he's one of those guys like if he's not
being funny I'll still probably laugh
because yeah like
reflex yeah he's like look at this guy
he's gonna talk about dicks or something
he's with the whole movie for him to say
dicks it is the evolution of like the
artist though because like you know Jim
Carrey he's like I'm not just a kamehame
actor even Jackie Chan right what's that
one movie 1911 or whatever he was like
not even really doing that much action
Foreigner yeah yeah he's just like
mainly just acting and I feel like
everyone they just like eventually they
want to evolve as an artist that might
be tired of what really wanted to do
that right he wanted some new stuff
smoking out that he wanted a role that
wasn't action against also good at
acting maybe we also wanted to sing too
do you want to sing yeah he wanted to
have an album too he's a really good
singer right yeah he's actually pretty
good Jackie Chan AI album right now
that's funny because he's not even a
comedian
we make that tonight yeah make him sing
like Kanye West song making Drake songs
first singer with an action genre
like Drake songs by Jackie Chan
his albums nothing was the chance
[Laughter]
you gotta like you gotta let funny
people be serious every now and then
they're also gonna [__] crack that's
right but I also think if you're acting
like you don't want to put your actual
Persona on TV because like let's say
you're actually funny and you're acting
and if you're just the same on camera
you're not really acting anymore you
know so if they're serious on camera
maybe they're really funny off camera
that happens a lot or I find a lot of
time it does happen a lot yeah a lot of
dramatic actors I meet like when I come
on to set and like I'm acting something
I'm just doing my regular bit and
they're like you are so funny how do you
do this I'm like whoa what the [__]
that's weird but a lot of people like
they don't have like that comedic
sensibility so you see a lot of also
dramatic actors try to be funny and flop
I feel like most of the time so you
gotta let them let actors flow and like
practice other [__] otherwise like I
don't know like Dave Chappelle who just
quits yeah that's true he's like they
just put them in a box do this 10 more
seasons he's like nah I'm good dude yeah
I'm out well I mean like when Adam
Sandler did uh funny people I was like
this is so not [__] funny you're like
boothing but it was good though yeah
about this movie
but I was expecting Happy Gilmore and I
got people a lot of people
you're expecting the same [__] jams dude
that was a good show yeah his Netflix
stuff now I really like it yeah yeah
ready to get it out that was a good
movie man I just needed a warning
because of the trailer the way they cut
it too it's called funny people it's
called funny people yeah funny people
threw everybody off because nobody knew
anything and they went in and exactly
what he has cancer
you have cancer
you got Seth Jonah it was about it was
about funny people like being real
high yeah yeah
and everyone was expecting comedy but it
was about comedians in their real life
yeah being all sad and [__] like I don't
want to see you off the stage uh it was
dope but I remember in the theater I
watched it in the theater and tons of
people were pissed people were really
mad about that I was one of those
if they Market it in a way where they
prep me like you're used to him being
funny but this time he's boring like the
90s preview guys in the world
I think most comedians or most comedic
actors writers whatever it is you can
kind of see a little bit of like hurt in
them somewhere in their routine all
crazy but I don't see the hurt in
Sandler I don't see the trauma yeah yeah
that's what okay that's living a pretty
chill so balanced yeah he's still
playing basketball and it's [__]
sweats and [__] off yeah he just seems
on probably still around right it seems
unbothered by a lot of stuff right like
even with all the fame that he has
everyone has like a really good story of
Adam Sandler just like walking by him
he's like hey how you doing he's very
pleasant you know all good stories like
when he went to the IHOP with his
daughter oh yeah it was that story he
went he went to IHOP with his daughter
and then they were like oh sorry it was
too full and he goes okay we'll go
somewhere else and then he takes his
daughter no he's legit like that name
drop or nothing like they didn't know it
was just fired right away you know who
that was yeah and they found out later
they were like oh come back we'll we'll
give you table anytime he's like no it's
fine like I don't want to teach my
daughter give him cancer that one movie
you know debut on YouTube I was a
regular person you know like I was you
still remember that you had a regular
job yeah at a restaurant called Volcano
in Pasadena shout out dude Schneider was
kind of a regular but not regular enough
to where like we always saw him but it
would be like oh he came on someone's
shift you know he came down one day and
then like six months will pass oh he
came down right one day
Rob Schneider Uh Kevin James Adam
Sandler and then uh this this bigger
lady this uh uh
no no no no she was a white lady but
it's that crude like they're uh
maybe she's she's an older blog
Betty White no no no no anyway well they
were they were they were there on my
shift yeah and I was like what the [__]
so we also had a bar so there was a
security they had to put like Velvet
Rope around them and then people were
leaving them alone yeah you know but
there were people that were trying to
sneak like shots and then some people
had those cameras and then you try to go
like that like
[Laughter]
yeah and then I was like oh my God the
curtain over his head
yeah and I was like busting the table
and [__] like this is their [__] they
barely ate anything I think they only
got like I don't know like 40 bucks
worth of food but they tipped like 200.
damn and then at the end of the night
they uh Adam Sandler said bye to every
single person like on the way out wow
I think the whole staff did the whole
like you know when you uh go outside and
line up because you just you just want
to see yeah so we all like like we're
there and then I think it was was like
oh he knew it was for him so he he kind
of said bye to every single person that
was nice man he's so cool yeah and I was
like damn this guy's really interesting
because we've had other celebrities come
into the restaurant before and they just
mind their own business and leave like
just regular people yeah he was a
superstar of the 2000s yeah like just
back to back to back no he's Legends
yeah he's in a small group I would hate
to be so I mean not I guess I can't wait
to be so famous one day or someone's
expecting a big tip from me and it just
doesn't come
on the receipt you should start on the
left side where you put like a one and
you leave all this space
and then just go no that's it
was here 10 years ago he gave me four
hundred dollars yeah so you guys tip
more when the person that's waiting you
as a fan yes yes I have to you have to
oh yeah but what's considered more like
five percent more I I don't go I
wouldn't go over 30 I don't think like
unless like if you're at someone that's
cheap 25 25 is Chill I used to give like
it's a fan I do 30. a lot of like a nice
ass place but what if they're a fan and
they're like not that good of a server I
have a big thing about it what happens
what do you do what's give them a
regular 20 regular 20. yeah because I
think you'll get five or Thirty city
server and like still get it over 20 too
but I think a lot of people think that
that's totally regular yeah they would
just pay waiters more that's a very
strange situation for them to be like
hey I'm a huge fan and then proceed to
give bad service yeah but some people
are just stupid though people don't even
know like I never ordered the strawberry
ice cream they're just they got brain
cell issues or something all over your
steak yeah
exactly like ice cream steak
how do I make this again well like let's
say you're on a diet right and then like
they want to hook you up so they're like
yo
um on the house and it's like all this
[__] crazy dessert and I'm all like
oh no
oh yeah I don't like getting hooked up
sometimes the pressure that comes with
getting hooked up yeah what does that
mean I have to do for you yeah that's
true you know um that's very true is
that an issue like a real issue like you
feel like shut up can't dude that's a
real issue man for sure it's an issue I
don't know yeah I mean like especially
like if I own a clothing brand and then
people like oh
this is my new clothing man they give me
like a bunch of stuff I feel so badly
like I'm literally Never Gonna wear it
I've got to wear it though for
competition reasons competitions you got
to put everyone else's shirt on oh it's
my friends for sure no no your enemies
oh yeah yeah but everybody should that's
what I do I was I walked into I go to
this Climbing gym now and there was this
pop-up these guys had like selling these
new shirts and I was like oh what's up
no this is cool I'll take two shirts
went home and I was like how can we be
better than that oh
like what a great businessman where's
the cut that's a cool cut right there
yeah let me write this what's your
Source I support them I bought the [__]
but also I'm like this is capitalism how
can I be better than the competitor here
I'm gonna open all those shirts that I
have at home yeah
try it out they're still in the package
they boom from the promotion
brand do you guys like not listen to
other people's podcasts
yeah tons of them I just don't feel like
we really compete with anyone because I
don't know it's about competing then I
guess just incorporating other [__] you
like yeah that's true yeah yeah do you
guys um watch and like consume content
that you don't even do yeah yeah like
homework no just like yeah just like
history stuff or whatever and then like
it's like it's just your sacred thing
that you enjoy but then you produce like
comedy or something else and then you
might not even consume comedy on YouTube
it always comes back for me because I
watch I love like documentaries I also
love Food Network like I love Food
Network I think I've seen everything
what's your favorite song my favorite
show is a trash show it's called a
Cutthroat Kitchen yeah it's like they
have sabotagers that you auction off and
then like there's a pot of 25 Grand
right it's one pot and then everyone has
25 Grand in front of them and they're
like hey for 10th hour 8 thousand
dollars you can force every Chef to wear
a blindfold but that's so funny and you
only leave with whatever you have left
in your case but you have to buy a
sabotage to [__] everyone else up it's
Chopped with sabotages wow
[Music]
so people leave with like three grand
because like they're spending money
sabotaging you know it's kind of worth
it Master Chef Junior where they have
the kids like compete against each other
and there's so so much pressure for like
it stuck have you watched it yeah the
kids on Chopped Junior suck they
shouldn't be on TV I'm sorry it's like a
piece of lettuce with a piece of cheese
on it it's like anybody can make that
like this is bad but yeah I watch Food
Network here's the channel but it always
comes back to a sketch writing a sketch
later oh I see I see I see like Jimmy
and I wrote this bit we haven't been
able to do it just time wise but we were
I was watching on chop the night was
like you guys are watching chop we both
started watching chopped and we had this
bit about how like it's always this
chefs with the saddest stories to win
Chopped it's not about being the best
shot yeah yeah like an amputee Chef or
something Chef what'd you make here like
oh I made this like you know foie gras
like oh what's your story Chef when I
was 18 my sister's house burned down
this fog raw is good
[Laughter]
good chefs on this one Chef whose dishes
are terrible they're a mess but he has
two hooks for hands
that a story every round and he just
keeps making it through the food it's
terrible
I feel like that I'll watch a bunch of
other [__] I'm like oh this would be
funny sushi with hooks the Plate's all
broken
because most of your ride you're toward
like TV and getting shows like that I'd
say like on the like on a weekly basis
most of my ideas I write down are like
probably sketch ideas like quick ones
but how I incorporate those now I try to
invest those into bigger projects I got
some shows have been developing like
Jimmy are working on a movie right now
and it's like I love this idea I can
just do an Instagram right now as a
sketch but I feel like I'll feel a
bigger payoff if I see this on the big
screen and like I put the money behind
it and I think this idea deserves so I
have all the ideas just about figuring
out which ones I want to see come to
life and language as a writer do you
practice just the art of writing
regardless if it's gonna go anywhere are
you like because uh you know like um
Spike Lee I think his his like routine
is he wakes up in the morning when he's
fresh and just for three hours a day
he's just writing yeah it doesn't matter
if it's gonna go anywhere he does it
unbiasedly not nothing about
monetization or anything and he just
writes and then maybe from there he'll
pull us all like this and this is he'll
make turn into a project like for you
who do you just write in general or do
you only write when you kind of notice a
destination yeah I think writing every
day is definitely the way to [__] do
it like if you can or reading every day
like write something down you know what
it is like I think like thank God I have
like some kind of idea every day so
it'll end up in a paragraph like in my
notes but I should get in a better habit
when I'm in a flow of like scripting
something or even just outlining
something every day yeah like the ideas
come quicker it's like when you work out
like when the muscles are warm
everything becomes easier like you hit
these like plateaus you know sooner hit
the Zone baby yeah say lubricated you
know what I mean you do more projects by
yourself
stay lubed up oh yeah that's a good
question you do more projects by
yourself or to do more projects with
Jimmy by myself by yourself yeah or like
with other collaborators oh cool in
different like writing groups yeah like
a couple different like writing partners
and then I have like some stuff I've
done like even if I nothing happens by
yourself right like even if I've like
developed I've developed a few series
you know without people that like are
prominent names you know I mean or like
have different random connections to me
um but those are like yeah I guess the
heart comes from me and then I find
collaborators after that but Jimmy and I
have so many like projects with like
legs that we can kind of just like come
back to look a few times a year like
we're doing right now like invest like
several weeks or several months and like
take a break and yes another show he
works on too did you work on the the
Netflix one no I didn't work on it okay
the high school one right yeah yeah
that's funny yeah and it was great yeah
yeah yeah it it feels like
um YouTube and that Golden Era of
sketches and everything that's where we
got our start too it it's all just on
reels or Tick Tock now yeah that's but
it's shorter less development I mean
it's funny that this is considered short
when our era that was three six minutes
was short you know yeah the art of a
sketch is completely changed yeah like
there's not many sketch artists anymore
I feel like I'm Tick-Tock on YouTube and
I'm on Tick Tock like a lot like I'm
just going through and like I feel like
I follow everyone who does a consistent
sketch comedy there's just not as big of
a place for it I feel like I don't know
I think kids look at comedy what makes
them laugh different now they want that
quick hit which is fine right it's just
fine right right quick hit yeah even the
Beat Drop video like that's like I feel
like that was a big jump like that's as
long as we've got to go through a 28
second video yeah like that's as long as
people really want to see 20 seconds is
too long these days yeah you just need a
hot girl to walk by and a guy goes and
then you're
yeah cause some of the people that
follow I don't even know what they're
doing like they'll be like a especially
like people that aren't Fitness comedy
realm like there's ones are just like
they go like that and then there's a
filter on dude Fitness comes in there's
like 20 million views I'm like huh yeah
most Fitness comedians need to [__]
stop
listen I love both those Realms so much
but I don't even know what's happening
like just stop
[__] yeah it seems like it's very just
like self-centered too like it's very
like egotistical like for sure so I
can't let you guys think you're [__]
funny half these dudes you're jacked for
sure good job they have so many views
that's the crazy is it because they're
just watching him have low standards for
comedy yes dude you know it's crazy so
it's relatable to that Niche right it's
like don't make a protein joke or a
bicep joke and then they all get it
right that's as funny as they could ever
be I see it'd be nice if it was that
it's abstract I don't even know what
they're making fun you know they're
joking yeah I don't even know it's just
like even if like someone walked by and
they go um again I know what's going on
yeah it's just like
and then 30 million views I'm like what
the [__] was that what is that that's
it can you post some on your stories
I'll show you right after the
compilation compilation one of the guys
I'm making fun of is the fan so I don't
want to call him out but I'll show you
right after
I've seen a couple dudes I've seen two
that can think of that have like made it
through why I saw them start off and on
like this kind of cringe and now I'm
like okay you managed to stay jacked and
funny yeah that's two out of like 2 000
though you know I got a good question
for you for another video because we're
up we're almost up out of time you I
mean that whole era of YouTube that we
were all in together the climate has
changed dramatically because that's been
over a decade right or almost a decade
and then so like people that got into
the game from back then and saw the
change of the social climate and all
that I want to hear your comments on it
as someone who's still working in comedy
thank you
foreign